(audience clapping)
- Now that you're in your second season,
have the Schmidt fans from New Girl,
have they accepted the new role?
The Neighborhood?
- I hope so (chuckles)
- I'm a fan of Schmidt,
so I love you in both.
I think it's awesome.
- No yeah,
it's been really cool
you know there's still a lot of New Girl
and Schmidt fans and you'll
be walking down the street
and somebody will go, "Schmidt!"
and you're like, oh my God, what happened.
- It's the greatest cast.
- Yeah It was such a wonderful experience
and I love when I get recognized for it.
I mean, I'm so grateful for it.
But now we have all these
people who are coming up to us
for The Neighborhood and they'll be like,
"I love your show",
and I'll be like, "Which one?"
- And then you sound like that guy.
Which one I have so many shows.
- Well I know, but I'm
actually curious about it,
because it's usually New Girl
and I'm like, I'm really
proud of this other one.
- Yeah, yeah.
I know, but it's funny cause now that
Netflix takes over everything so everybody
that hasn't seen, like
New Girl was on for years,
and they're just now starting.
- Well you can kind of guess
who's coming up to you for what show
because you'll have some pinned out teen
who's like "I love your show"
and you're like did you
just watch all seven seasons
of New Girl in a weekend?
(audience laughs)
- Like one weekend. (laughs)
- Yeah and they're like,
"yes and it was amazing,
when you and Winston..."
and you're like all right man let's just
let's sit down, let's get a coffee,
everything--
- [Kelly] Hash this out.
- Everything's gonna be fine,
you just need to breathe.
- Yes, and have you heard
of The Neighborhood.
- That's right.
But then you'll have people who will come
and it's like, "man I love
the show, you and Cedric",
and it's been a really,
this show is, it's on CBS,
it's really more of a
family oriented show,
and so you're having
conversations with people
who are like "yeah you
know we get the whole
family together, we watch the show,
it's got such a positive message",
and we love doing the show.
- That's a great outlook.
- Thanks.
- So what kind of real
life neighbor are you,
are you one that like, you
make friends or you hide?
- I feel like I'm a nice neighbor
because I'm anticipating my kids
throwing something through--
- [Kelly] (laughs) breaking.
- A window of a neighbor of mine or like,
being like "we should
totally prank the neighbors".
My kids saying this, like
that's an idea they would have.
- I did this weird thing,
I'm owning this on national television
but whenever I was a
kid, me and my friend,
I don't know why we did it
but we would make phone calls
and we'd be like,
"yeah we wanna go to,
have a flight to Jamaica,
(fake laughs) yeah we need
to leave Tuesday the 16th",
we're like laughing and it's not funny,
it's not funny, like it's not even funny,
we were so stupid we weren't
even funny at our joke
but we did it and we
thought we were hilarious.
- No I was like well what was the prank--
- They're gonna think we're
coming to go to Jamaica.
- Yeah, what was the
prank and they'd be like,
"we ordered a pizza" (Kelly laughs)
and you're like...
- You rebel.
- Yeah I'm like this is,
at least nail the bit.
- That's what I'm saying it
wasn't even funny (laughs).
All right well are you the dad who gets
over involved, are you a helicopter dad?
Do you get overly involved?
- Uh.
- That means yes, you hesitated.
- Yeah. (audience laughs)
- Yeah yeah.
Um, how do I answer this.
You are, you're afraid
they're gonna fall or,
you're always kind of hovering?
- I'm very like,
I've gotten over that to some extent,
I'm very please-y though,
meaning, so you know
it's Halloween coming up.
- Yeah.
- And so last year there was an incident
in which my daughter went to school
and her costume was Hermione
Granger from Harry Potter,
she was really excited, we
were excited, that's right.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] That's right she's cute.
- So she was really excited
and she went to school
she did like the school parade
and she came home and we had,
we live in a good neighborhood
for trick-or-treating
and right before people
were gonna come over
cause we were having some people over
we were all gonna go out together,
I just hear a commotion in the other room,
and I can hear the tone is upset,
and I walk in I go, what's going on,
she's like I don't have my cape,
and I go why don't you just
throw on like a T-shirt
or something and she was like,
"no, Hermione Granger is
nothing without her cape"
(audience laughs)
and I go, well where is it,
she goes, "I think I left it at school",
I go (sighs), I'll go to the school.
So I like get in the car,
I run over to the school,
there's no cape,
and I call the house from the school phone
and I'm like, where is it?
And she's like "I don't know".
So I finally am like,
I don't know what to do I've
been here for 45 minutes,
I'm like leaving,
I see in the corner of the schoolyard
this bundled up black piece of cloth
and I go, that can't be it,
and I run over and I pull
it up and I go, this idiot.
(audience laughs)
And so I run to my car at
this point I'm sweating
I'm like barreling through traffic,
they're about to start to
go out to trick-or-treat,
I get home, I run through the door,
Lily and all her friends
are running around
I'm like, here's your cape,
and she's like "thanks Dad",
and then runs off.
(audience laughs)
- And that's why I would have
just given her the sheet.
They don't appreciate it.
- And now I'm like hyperventilating,
I'm literally on the floor,
my wife walks by and goes
"where have you been?"
(audience laughs)
- Uh, just saving the day, you're welcome.
Kids are like that though
you go above and beyond
that's why I've learned just don't,
just don't go above and beyond.
- Yeah no, I know.
You know what you gotta set them up
life will have disappointments
this is the first one,
it's fine.
- I know, I know.
- It's fine. You're such a good person.
- I'm making up for a lot
of mistakes (Kelly laughs).
- Okay do you help with
homework like all of that,
are you that kind of dad?
- Big time.
- Yeah?
God you're so good.
- There is a part of me that's like,
we're getting into some
more stuff and I'm like,
I wonder how I'm gonna do in fourth grade.
- Dude.
- Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Like she'll get tests
back and she's like,
"I got an 84" and I'm like,
we got an 84.
(audience laughs)
- This is why, I like
doing homework with them,
but I feel like the older they get
they just get lazy about it if
I'm sitting there with them.
They'll be like, "oh I don't know",
I start getting the I don't know answer
and I'm like I'm out, nope,
you're just being lazy.
- I try to read where they're at mentally,
I shouldn't say they're,
our son's four he doesn't get homework.
- [Kelly] (laughs) from Montessori.
- If she's like wiped out,
you know she does a lot
of after school stuff
she's on the basketball team
and I can see that
we're barely holding on,
let's sit down and do this together
and I'll walk you through it.
- Yeah, I have my moments,
but sometimes I'm like,
you're on your own dude.
- There's a lot of that.
- I'm like you're just being lazy
and want me to do the problem
and I'm not gonna do it
cause I don't know how to do fifth grade,
like I don't know how.
(audience laughs)
So you're like whatever.
Hope you nail it! (laughs)